Testes originally form in the abdomen near
the stomach and kidneys.
The nerves and blood vessels remain attached
in that region, even after the balls drop.
So when a guy gets kicked in the balls or
otherwise has his nuts squished, the pain
involved travels up from each testicle into
the abdominal cavity, via the spermatic plexus,
which is the primary nerve of each testicle,
and then to the spine.
In addition to the pain in the stomach area,
many men also experience severe nausea.
This is thought to be caused by a huge rush
of sympathetic nervous system discharge.
So the body’s tolerance level for that rush
determines whether that person will be someone
susceptible to actually vomiting when
kicked
in
the nuts.